rappelez-vous nous avions déjà évoqué
cette affaire en août 2021 au Château de
Brou à Noyant-de-Touraine une femme de
44 ans a été décédée durant un stage de
jeunes prolongés l'organisateur de cette
cure un naturopathe de 58 ans vient
d'être mis en examen par le procureur de
Tours et incarcéré notamment pour
homicide involontaire et exercices
illégal des professions de médecins et
pharmaciens deux autres personnes sont
décédées suite à secure Aurélie Renaud
et les premiers jours de jeûne devraient
être assez facile sur sa chaîne Youtube
le naturopathe donné des conférences il
faisait également témoigner des
stagiaires le jeûne leur aurait permis
de vaincre des cancers en août 2021 Éric
Gandon organise un stage de jeûne à
Noyant de Touraine au Château de Brou le
12 août les gendarmes de Sainte-Maure
sont avisés du décès d'une participante
elle avait 44 ans elle était originaire
de Paris malgré le décès l'organisateur
décide de poursuivre le stage interdit
par la suite par la préfecture le séjour
consistait à ne rien manger on parle de
jeunes hydriques une méthode très
dangereuse selon les médecins et le
comaï polysémique c'est quelque chose
qui existe si vous tombez dans le coma
vous pouvez vous pouvez donc être avoir
une détresse respiratoire enfin tout ça
ça peut s'enchaîner de façon très très
rapide aucune étude à ma connaissance ne
prouve l'efficacité de quelques manières
que ce soit du jeûne d'un jeune prolongé
rien même c'est des gens qu'on veut
essayer de faire maigrir ces gens sont
surveillés l'enquête confiait à un juge
d'instruction révèle que quatre plaintes
ont été déposées par des stagiaires
d'une naturopathe des personnes qui
considéraient que leur santé avait été
mise en danger durant les formations
nous avons contacté l'un des
participants aucun médecin n'était
présent le suivi se faisait via des
réunions chaque matin
chacun raconte ancien tour de table
comme ça les gens donc en même temps les
gens prenaient leur tension se poser et
la personne qui est décédée n'était pas
venue autour de table
franchement
interpeller en Vendée à Paris
Eric Gandon et son fils de 25 ans qui
participait à l'organisation des stages
ont été placés en garde à vue le 10
janvier dernier au domicile Derrick
Gandon 32000 euros ont été trouvés ce
dernier a été mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui et exercices illégal de
la profession de médecins les deux mises
en examen contestent l'effet qui leur
sont reprochés Éric Gondon a été écroué
il encourt trois ans de prison et 375000
euros d'amende